euh alors qui était victime du gros
arnaque autour de cette table on va tous
Daniel Daniel vous alors vous c'est
est-ce que c'est vraiment une arnaque
finalement
je raconte ou enfin
je sais pas si c'est une arnaque mais
enfin quand même j'ai passé un jour mais
il y a très longtemps à casting pour
faire des doublages de voix j'étais un
peu je connaissais des gens dans le
métier et ils me font faire plusieurs
scènes dont une scène très très érotique
on va dire et il me disent c'est c'est
obligatoire il faut vraiment ça remonte
c'est comme ça qu'on montre sa voiture
et je suis plus tard qu'en fait ma scène
a été utilisée dans un vrai film très
très érotique
la voici circule sur un film peut-être
les suceuses sont au parfum
retourne-toi que je marque un but ou
enfin des trucs comme ça quoi
vous êtes une arnaque ambulante mais
il se trouve que je suis une figure
iconique dans les anciens pays de l'Est
c'est ça
Dracula
énormément voilà et donc mon image
j'allais beaucoup dans les pays de l'Est
à une époque quand j'étais envoyé
spécial de l'équipe en Ukraine en
Roumanie dans tous les pays de l'Est et
donc la presse locale faisait des photos
de moi et ma photo a été pillée par des
sites de rencontres notamment en
Azerbaïdjan au Tadjikistan je suis une
icône et on me pillait pour des sites de
rencontres un peu pornographiques ou
érotique parce que là-bas on met ma
photo et des centaines de femmes à flux
dans l'autre sens
iconique et j'ai été pillé mon visage a
servi de modèle
au Japon
[Applaudissements]
en fait assez fréquente que beaucoup de
gens ont subi c'est à dire qu'on ne m'a
pas rendu un dépôt de garantie j'ai loué
une maison et on m'a pas rendu le dépôt
de garantie sauf que là c'était une
somme assez conséquente
c'est plus de 10000 dollars quand même
et donc ça fait un château non non pas
du tout non mais il fallait donner
plusieurs mois plusieurs mois de dépôt
de garantie et j'ai pas pu attaquer la
propriétaire pour récupérer mon argent
parce qu'elle était avocate elle-même et
donc les frais que j'aurais engagés
étaient supérieurs à ce que j'allais
pouvoir récupérer
une maison pour un tournage de de
télé-réalité et c'était une maison
magnifique qui était à Antibes il y
avait des grosses portes en chêne ça
fait très très belle vraiment d'écouter
genre 3-4000 5000 euros 10000 euros là
je pense la porte il fallait faire
passer des câbles pour pour le tournage
et
on va juste essayer de quelque chose
on a rendu à la maison le dépôt de
garantie non seulement je n'ai pas
récupéré mais on m'a demandé un autre
parce que toutes les portes évidemment
alors
si j'étais arnaqué parce que à l'amour
bah je me suis fait alors arnaqué que un
jour m'a proposé une arnaque et comme un
con je me suis dit il y a pas de raison
que tout le monde croque et que moi je
croque pas et c'est la fameuse époque de
la taxe carbone et un mec moi
il n'était pas dans le truc mais c'était
soi-disant un compère à lui et on m'a
dit si tu donnes un peu d'argent on va
faire fructifier ça c'est une arnaque
méthode sera pas mêlée à l'arnaque
t'inquiète pas ton nom sera jamais cité
etc il fallait donner un minimum de
10000 euros 20000 euros j'ai pris toutes
mes économies j'avais 20000 euros j'ai
donné mes 20000 euros et évidemment je
n'ai jamais rien vu sans garantis en
rien sans rien ben non parce que quand
tu fais une arnaque tu signes pas un
papier tu es pas débile non plus tu es
un pigeon
évidemment c'était pas du tout une
arnaque d'attaque carbone ça servait
seulement à faire bien vivre dans les
restaurants les boîtes de nuit le mec à
qui j'avais donné mon argent c'est
vraiment j'ai pas pu porter plainte
parce que j'avais pas les commissariat
lui apportez bien j'ai mis un peu dans
le carbone et c'est ça
j'étais entendu par les flics quand même
ah bah évidemment